Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain an American comedy
fantasy film called “Click.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie starts as we see the main protagonist,
Michael Newman, who is an architect by profession.
He lives with his family of four which include
his wife Donna and two children, Ben and Samantha.
Michael’s heavy-handed boss John Ammer makes
him work more than necessary and as a result,
Michael often ends up ignoring his family.
Despite all this, Michael finds a lot of joy
out of the little time he gets to spend with
his children like when he watches Dragon Tales
with them before leaving for work.
One day at work, John offers Michael a once
in a lifetime opportunity to design a luxury
hotel for a Japanese conglomerate.
He also promises Michael a promotion if he
is able to seal the contract.
Michael is elated by the proposition but realizes
that he has to go camping with his family.
Later, he also misses Ben’s swimming race.
When Michael reaches the school, he is greeted
by Ben’s swimming teacher Bill with whom
Ben seems to have a good friendship.
He instantly becomes jealous as he isn’t
able to spend much time with his son.
Hence, he makes fun of Bill’s red speedo.
As the family gathers at the fourth of July
fireworks, Michael spends all his time on
the phone with his boss, which begins to annoy
Michael’s mother Trudy.
She complains that Michael will die early
if he continues to overwork and eat junk food.
As Michael is occupied on the phone, his father
Ted entertains the kids with his quarter trick.
Fascinated by the trick, Ben and Samantha
ask their grandfather how he managed to bend
the coin but Ted responds that “a magician
never reveals his secrets”.
Ted further adds that even the “big boy”
Michael hasn’t been able to decode his secret.
Later at home, an argument erupts when Michael
tells Donna to postpone the camping trip.
He eventually calms her down and starts his
project research by watching an Asian architecture
documentary.
However, he hurts himself when he accidentally
mistakes Ben’s helicopter remote for the
TV remote.
Tired of always mixing up the remotes, Michael
heads out to the supermarket to buy a universal
remote control.
Michael enters the retail store Bed Bath & Beyond.
He looks everywhere for the remote but doesn’t
find it.
A tired Michael then collapses on a bed.
When he turns around, he spots a section of
the store called “Beyond”.
When he gets inside to inspect, he is welcomed
by a mysterious man named Morty.
Michael begins to explain about his situation
to Morty, who then takes Micahel to a large
warehouse called “Way Beyond”.
Morty then grabs a weird looking remote and
offers it to Michael for free.
Morty tells Michael that the remote will program
itself when he points and clicks the buttons.
A confused Michael inquires why he is being
given the remote for free, to which Morty
responds that “Good guys need a break every
once in a while”.
As Michale prepares to leave, he is also told
that the item is ‘non refundable.’
After Michael reaches home, he continues watching
the documentary and begins working on the
project design.
However, he is soon disturbed by his dog Sundance.
The poor doggo wants a break outside so he
continues to bark.
A furious Michael then points the remote at
Sundance and presses the volume down button
repeatedly, while shouting at the dog to remain
silent for five minutes.
Astonishingly, the dog becomes mute but Michael
dismisses it as he thinks it's just a hallucination.
After Michael takes Sundance out, he starts
getting frustrated again as the dog takes
really long to find a spot to relieve himself.
So he points the remote at the dog again,
while pressing fast forward.
Just like the last time, the trick works,
as the remote fastracks sundance, who quickly
finishes his work and gets back inside.
Michael is astonished and finally believes
the power of the universal remote.
He finds out that the remote can be used to
control real life.
The following day, Michael uses the remote
to look into his past life.
He gets emotional when he sees his little
self play football with his friends at lake
Winnipesaukee.
Meanwhile, Morty gives Michael his phone number
in case he has any questions about the remote.
Michael uses the remote to fast forward through
family dinner, arguments and even intercourse.
After fast-forwarding the intercourse, Michael
is surprised to learn that he “climaxed”
very quickly, and couldn’t pleasure Donna
like he normally used to.
He also learns that he doesn’t remember
the conversations he had or commitments he
made during the dinner.
Michael calls Morty and demands an explanation
for it.
Morty says that during fast forward, his body
is on "auto-pilot".
This means that he is going through the motions
of everyday life but his mind skips ahead.
In this way, while Michael seems to live a
normal life, he doesn’t remember any of
it.
After this revelation, Michael uses the remote
to fast forward through undesirable things
like sickness, cold showers, and traffic.
He also presents the design he made on auto-pilot
mode to the Japanese businessman Mr. Watsuhita.
The meeting seems to be going great but Michael’s
over excited boss John unintentionally mocks
Japan’s iconic baseball players, mistaking
their name for Asian dishes.
This prompts Mr. Watsushita to excuse himself
and have a private conversation with his team.
A nervous Michael tries to overhear Watsuhita's
conversation, but can't understand any of
it.
So, he uses the remote to translate their
conversation into English and turn up their
volume.
The trick works, and it reveals that the Japanese
team disliked Michael's design, commenting
that it must have been made after watching
a bad documentary on Asian architecture.
They wanted more rooms to maximize their profits
and not a stupid river in the lobby.
Mr. Watsuhita then orders his team to end
the meeting so that they can have Jello shots
at America’s greatest cultural achievement:
TGI Friday’s.
However, when Mr. Watsuhita approaches Michael
to wrap up, he uses the overheard conversation
to win over the businessman.
He rips his failed design and offers to make
a new one to incorporate more rooms to maximise
profits.
A delighted Mr. Watsuhita finally grants the
contract to Michael’s company.
Later at home, a super elated Michael buys
gifts for his wife and children.
When Donna inquires about the reason for Michael's
joy, he reveals that John has promoted him
to a partnership.
Donna jumps in excitement.
However, the excitement turns into disappointment
the next day, when Michael learns that he
hasn’t been promoted.
As a matter of fact, he won’t be promoted
until he prepares the construction plan for
the hotel and gets Mr. Watsuhita's commitment,
which will take him several months.
Devastated by the news, Michael uses the remote
to pause John and fart in his mouth.
In the next scene, Michael plans on using
the remote to fast forward to the time he
finishes the Watsuhita project.
When he seeks Morty’s advice, Morty reminds
Michael about the leprechaun from a cereal
advertisement.
The leprechaun always chases a pot of gold
at the end of the rainbow but when he finally
gets there, he realises it is just cornflakes.
Michael doesn’t understand the metaphor
but nevertheless suspends his plans to use
the remote.
At home, Michael is still frustrated over
his promotion and takes it out on his children.
The kids start crying when Michael makes fun
of their pizza and pickles.
He then has an argument with Donna.
Later, Michael realises his mistake.
He is annoyed by his actions so he finally
decides to use the remote to skip ahead to
his promotion and finds himself at his promotion
party.
He finds out that it took John a whole year
to promote him.
During this time, Donna and Michael’s relations
started to get strained and they entered marriage
counseling.
Ben and Samantha have matured and no longer
watch the Dragon tales cartoon.
He also learns that Sundance has passed away.
Michael breaks down and regrets not letting
his late dog hump his leg.
This confuses Donna but she consoles him anyway.
Michael promises Donna that he will change
and become a better man for her.
He asks her to not leave him.
Michael and Donna make out but the remote
automatically fast forwards to the end of
the intercourse.
Michael again finds an unsatisfied Donna lying
next to him on bed.
He is puzzled by the remote automatically
skipping time without him pressing any buttons.
He then contacts Morty, who reveals that the
remote is now using its memory to execute
Michael’s preferences.
That’s google way ahead of its time!
Michael fast forwarded through an entire year
and that accounted for a lot of intercourse
skipped.
Now each time he tries having intercourse
or involves in events like showering, driving
through traffic, arguing, and being sick,
the remote is going to fast forward on its
own.
Hearing this, Michael regrets having ever
used the remote and returns the remote to
Morty but it automatically reappears in his
hand.
He then makes several attempts to discard
and destroy the remote but it reappears each
time.
The next day, Michael goes to office on a
bicycle without showering so that he can avoid
the time being automatically fast forwarded.
There, John tells him about his plans to retire
and travel to Morocco.
John’s retirement would make Michael the
new head of the International Division at
the firm.
While Michael is stunned by his promotion
to such a high post, John exclaims that every
account Michael has worked on has turned into
gold.
John also comments that he wouldn’t be surprised
if one day Michael ended up being their company's
CEO.
Suddenly, Michael is fast-forwarded ten years
into the future, where he is wealthy, but
morbidly obese.
He quickly returns home to find that Ben and
Samantha are grown up teenagers.
Ben too has become an obese guy much like
himself while Samantha has started dating
someone.
He also learns that Donna has divorced him
and is dating Ben’s swimming teacher Bill.
Enraged by their relationship, Michael attacks
Bill.
An argument ensues and the family dog jumps
on Michael, causing him to knock his head
on the wall and fall unconscious.
After six long years, Michael finally gains
consciousness.
Donna is there by his side, who reveals that
after he went into a coma, a CAT scan found
cancer in his body, so he had to undergo treatment
for years.
After beating cancer, he had a heart attack
too.
However, Michael is no longer fat as a result
of having undergone liposuction to save his
life.
Later at the firm, Michael meets an adult
Ben, who has surprisingly lost a lot of weight
working out with Donna’s husband Bill.
Michael offers to take Ben, Samantha, and
their grandparents out for an ice cream but
Ben reveals that grandpa Ted has already died.
This devastates Michael who breaks into tears
and visits Ted’s grave.
Michael then uses the remote to re-experience
the time when he last saw his dad.
Michael sees that Ted dropped by his office
and offered to take Ben and him out for dinner.
But an autopilot Michael rejected the offer
without even looking at the old man.
Ted continued to insist and offered to show
Michael his favorite childhood quarter trick
but an agitated Michael yelled at his father,
while revealing that he had always known the
secret to the trick.
The poor old man then apologized and left
with tears in his eyes.
Michael gets filled with shame and guilt.
Morty then appears and apologises for taking
his father away, admitting that he is the
Angel of Death.
Michael gets angry by the revelation and attacks
Morty.
However, Morty disappears into thin air and
reappears behind him.
Frightened, Michael asks the remote to take
him to a "good place" whereupon the remote
fast-forwards him several more years in the
future to Ben's wedding.
At the wedding, Michael is elated to see his
mother and gives her a long kiss.
He also meets an all grown
up Samantha.
Michael hears her calling Bill “dad” and
suffers from a heart attack, unable to bear
the pain of being replaced even as a father.
He wakes in the hospital that night with Ben
and Samantha by his side.
Before Ben and Samantha are escorted out by
the nurse, Michael finds out that Ben is skipping
his honeymoon because of a business deal.
Fearing that Ben might make the same mistakes
he made, Michael gathers the last of his strength
to follow them out of the hospital.
However, his body gives out and he collapses
onto the ground, with his family around him.
In a very low voice, he suggests Ben to always
put family first and apologises to Samantha
for not being there for her.
Michael then tells Donna that he will always
love her and passes away.
Suddenly, Michael reawakens in Bed Bath & Beyond.
He is elated to learn that everything was
just a dream.
Outside, he is overjoyed to see his “crappy,
mediocre, middle class” car.
After he reaches home, he embraces his family
and promises to spend more time with them.
Just then, he then finds the remote on the
counter along with a note from Morty, which
says that he has been given a second chance
as "Good guys need a break."
Morty also hopes that Michael will do the
right thing this time.
The movie ends as Michael throws the remote
in the trash and gets delighted as this time,
it does not reappear.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.